-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys,
I'm so excited about this.
From the mega hit show,
"Stranger Things,"
Millie Bobby Brown
is my guest tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My fave.
Well,
speaking of "stranger things,"
Kanye West is in the news.
[ Laughter ]
After losing his deal
with Adidas,
Kanye showed up,
unannounced, yesterday
at Skechers headquarters
and was escorted out.
[ Laughter ]
That's too bad,
'cause if there's one company
that could help him "shape up,"
it's Skechers.
You know, you'd think --
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Yeah, when Kanye showed up,
the CEO said, "Call security."
And his assistant was like,
"This is Skechers.
We don't have security."
[ Laughter ]
I feel like, pretty soon,
Kanye's gonna hit up
whoever makes those
free paper sandals
after you get a pedicure.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of "stranger things,"
Elon Musk is in the news.
Elon Musk is close to buying
Twitter, and, yesterday,
he walked into their
headquarters carrying a sink
just so that he could tweet --
this is real --
"Entering Twitter HQ.
Let that sink in."
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Come on.
-That pun cost him $44 billion.
Worth it?
I think so.
Just when you thought Kanye
made the most bizarre entrance,
Elon was like, "Hold my sink."
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Well, you guys, Halloween
is just a few days away.
You excited about Halloween?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I read that the top three
candies in the U.S.
are Reese's, Skittles,
and M&M's.
Those are all pretty solid.
Tariq,
what's your favorite candy?
-Mine?
I like Junior Mints.
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
-Swedish Fish?
-Nah, bish.
-Wax lips?
-Goes to my hips.
[ Laughter ]
-Starburst?
-Could be worse.
-Now and Later?
-I ain't a hater.
-Mike and Ike?
-I do not like.
-Raisinets?
-I would not get.
-Red Vines?
-Always divine.
-Lifesavers?
-Every flavor.
-Bit-O-Honey?
-Ha-ha! You're funny.
-Dum Dums?
-Yum, yum, yum.
-Jujubes?
-Bitch, please!
[ Laughter ]
-Goo Goo Cluster?
-Hell yeah, mother [bleep]
-Cotton candy?
-Sweetie, go!
-♪ Let me see that
tootsie roll ♪
♪ Oh, tootsie roll ♪
♪ Tootsie roll ♪
♪ Tootsie roll,
let me see that tootsie roll ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-All that for just --
-Switching gears, uh...
[ Laughter ]
After finishing their annual
nuclear exercises,
today, Vladimir Putin said
that Russia would not use
nuclear weapons in Ukraine.
People are like, "Okay. But what
about the other countries?"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, of course,
it's election season,
and there's a weird story
from Pennsylvania.
Apparently,
a Democrat named Mike Doyle
is retiring from Congress,
and the Republican candidate
to replace him
is actually named Mike Doyle.
[ Laughter ]
While the outgoing Democrat,
Mike Doyle,
doesn't want the Republican
Mike Doyle to win his seat,
so he just released this ad.
Take a look.
-Mike Doyle says he'll take care
of Pennsylvania voters,
but can we really trust
someone like Mike Doyle?
-Hi, I'm Mike Doyle,
and I'm a name you can trust,
unlike Mike Doyle.
So, listen to me, Mike Doyle,
and stay the hell away
from Mike Doyle.
On election day,
don't vote for this man,
Mike Doyle -- no, wait.
That's me.
Avoid this this guy.
Wait.
Is that me or him?
[Bleep]
I don't even know anymore.
-This has been a message from
the Mike Doyle
Against Mike Doyle PAC.
-Mike Doyle, Mike Doyle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, get this, guys,
I heard that Pfizer
is being investigated
for allegedly hiding
more than a billion dollars
in profit
by transferring money
to other countries.
Yeah, not good.
Well, in response,
Pfizer went ahead and released
this statement, and they said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It sounds serious.
-Wow.
-Pfight.
-Pfight --
Pfight me, sorry, yeah.
Well, some entertainment news.
Henry Cavill says that, in his
next performance as Superman,
he'll be playing a, quote,
"Enormously joyful Superman."
We actually have an early clip
of enormously joyful Superman.
Take a look at this.
-I know you're trying to find
out where I hang my cape.
You won't.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Looks good.
I can't wait.
-I can't wait to see it.
-Yeah.
I saw a new report that says
that people should not rake
all the leaves out of their yard
because it's actually better
for your lawn's health.
So, I think, with that in mind,
it's time to say goodbye
to my rake.
Rake, are you there?
-A lifetime of autumns together
and this is how I find out
I'm fired.
-Come on, rake,
don't think of it as fired.
Think of it as retiring.
You can now
do anything you want.
-Man, I want to rake leaves.
Fall is my whole personality.
-Look, your future
is what you make it.
We'll see you in the spring,
when it's time
to clear the flower beds.
-You're right, Jimmy.
Hey, we had
some good times, though.
Remember high school?
[ Laughter ]
I used to hang out with you
and your friends.
Watching you guys play hoops,
hoping you'd take a rake break.
[ Laughter ]
Who was that guy that used
to pour out half his Gatorade
then fill the empty half
with Yoo-Hoo
and call it Gator-Hoo?
[ Laughter ]
Ed Zipperton.
Man, that guy was cool.
He pantsed me at prom
while I was dancing alone
to "Lady in Red."
It was the part where it goes...
[ Laughs ]
♪ The lady in red ♪
-Yeah, it was.
-♪ Is dancing with me ♪
♪ Cheek to cheek ♪
[ Laughter ]
Then, shoop!
That's the sound
of my pants going down.
And the worst part is, my pants
got caught on my prom boots.
Yeah, the tuxedo rental man
at the mall tricked me
into paying extra for something
called prom boots.
[ Laughter ]
They were just Dr. Martens that
he spray-painted bright green.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, wait!
I forgot.
I'm supposed to be doing
the voice of a rake.
[ Laughter ]
Not reciting
a page from my diary.
-This has been another edition
of "Making James Read Lines
He's Never Seen Before."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-I miss that rake.
Guys, listen to this.
A new study found that,
in the U.S., deli meat is linked
to more than 90%
of all listeria cases.
Right now,
the CEO of Blimpie is like,
"Well, that's what you get
for using real meat."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
this is very interesting.
A new survey found that you can
have the best chance
of surviving
a zombie apocalypse in Florida.
I wonder why that is.
-[ Scoffs ]
Because even zombies
are too afraid to visit Florida.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
No.
You know what?
I'm tired of all
the Florida slander.
We always make fun of Florida,
but I'm putting my foot down.
It's a great state
full of great people.
-Listen to this next story.
A Florida man
is accused of spiking his
co-worker's drink with bleach.
-See?
Florida is scary, dude.
-Oh, come on. I'm sure he had
a perfectly good reason.
-He confessed to deputies,
saying he wanted
to get back at his co-worker
for "being difficult."
[ Laughter ]
-"Being difficult"?
-That's just one guy.
It's a random
workplace incident.
Not everyone in Florida
is chasing people around,
trying to hurt them.
-A Florida man is accused of
chasing two people with knives.
[ Laughter ]
-You're done.
You're done, man.
Case closed.
-I mean -- I mean,
it was just only a knife.
-They say he didn't stop
with the knives.
He also grabbed an axe.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm telling you, man,
Florida is scary!
-That's a fluke
between a few people.
It's not like he was knocking on
doors in the wee hours
of the morning
while wielding a machete.
-A man in a South Florida
neighborhood knocking on doors
in the wee hours of the morning
while wielding a machete.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-Look, at least they're keeping
it within state lines.
You know, it's not like they're
coming to your house
and stealing the food
out of your mouth.
-Three Florida men were arrested
in a multi-million dollar
theft ring of stolen meat
across the Midwest.
-What's your excuse this time?
-Maybe they were -- they were
giving the food to the needy.
-The men were selling the meat
on the black market.
-All right, forget it!
Let's talk about something else!
I'm not --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, Essentia water
has teamed up
with a boxed-wine company
to sell water and wine
in one box.
Look at this.
Yeah.
In a related story, they're
currently being sued by Jesus.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show!